hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing Coco CR with black so we have or
the for the Petrov okay I have to do it
again and III it's not really aggressive
right
I need supply of a move of course it's
basically philidor's with the colors
reversed which probably why does not
worse just have to prevent before it's
really okay this is the signal that
white probably and tends to take on d5
at some point take and use the night on
use the night on seafoam doesn't look
like it like he wants to do that
interesting I can do form night h5 let's
try if I can get two affordances we've
really a very usually a good thing let's
see
the Knight g5 tactic doesn't work I can
take with the rook so oftentimes in a
point okay I think I'm going to take
which looks a little bit odd but and
once you get in Queen to f6 and then
Knight reform that's my plan and he
cannot mean like Bishop e5 could be a
thing but just really matter here I came
or taking no jumps to have four
you might take on a seven now after
which night takes is an interesting move
maybe to be ready to play like even play
93 this is much we we know almost for
sure
and then I have c6 maybe still rook
takes a strong way of 97's probably okay
okay I'm not unhappy about all this but
thinking about it an interesting tactic
that I might have here as Bishop takes
g4 and then the check on g6 something to
keep in mind yeah okay so Bishop is six
he cannot easily move the bishop from e2
because of Knight age three check yeah
I'm not sure a man like this Knight
takes a seven business I was originally
quite happy with the idea but looking at
it again it doesn't feel fantastic in
the other end it's not so easy to give
white a clear advice what you should do
yeah I should have taken with the rook
probably
it is a bit odd what does he have no
match if he wants to play Knight g4 with
the tempo Knights ehm looks very very
normal
well then I have kun said ok I'll just
have queenie 7 okay yeah over to g6
I guess p6 would have been possible as
well but probably I should have taken
with a look just play like night a 7087
go 7 directly yeah ok
maybe Bishop III was a move him
I didn't really see this one
it's annoying you know a queen has snow
square
yeah I'm not too happy with with how
that turned out
probably not worse but not so not in any
any form better they thought when I came
to f4 again maybe I'm a little bit
better but didn't really materialize I
have to go which we have six with this
piece
yeah take it and now maybe there is
Knight takes e4 in some cases 94 there
is Knight takes h6 it's still it's the
central pawn maybe I should still do it
31 seconds
don't like how I played this really not
it's a bit of a pain for him now before
his hanging and I have Queenie for next
potentially okay so he's attacking e5 +
f6 not a good move so this one probably
should have at least considered this
it's pretty pretty awful that I didn't
I definitely don't want to make a draw
it is a bit risky okay
you could have taken this one with chick
oh you know sometime that is helpful
okay yeah that McGill I I think I'm
better now
I have consolidated the pawn but yeah
that was not very convincing some
interesting moments that were like here
I think we we should be this is about
evil and I went for this night age 5
maneuver right if one an archaic take
and Queen f6 is a fairly normal way to
play it this is also very standard he
took and now I mean I was talking about
this quite a bit during the game I
should probably take with this and after
93 play 97 that was not something that I
was aware of it's a lot quicker way to
get the night back into the game and may
be allowed to play c6 later yeah this is
probably just losing time even though
other position is like there's nothing
going on like directly so I don't think
there's a huge problem with what I did
it's just not very precise 56 that
didn't help
again there and again here but it's
totally symmetrical so it's it takes
some some more bear moves to get in any
sort of trouble yeah here I think we're
just talking about in equal position at
age 5 went before maybe widest iv4
choice which cannot be much 5 yeah I
know I decided to to unbalance the whole
thing I interesting that the engine
gives 95 but it's probably just
completely equal right this maybe not
you know because the points here could
be a liability
I have six maybe yeah but I think it
even that should be a roughly equal so
he took in there should be five and
tried to play actively to ship here King
just seven yeah
and it's probably still roughly equal
but at least it's a there's a little bit
of an on symmetry there ninety seven
ninety three ninety three four ninety
five also yes me though so probably then
this is stronger operating with the pin
now and here it gets a little bit
annoying you know I'm better but Quincy
three is probably wrong here that isn't
it so drawing I have to play up six
immediately yeah I cannot really get out
of the checks I mean I he could have
taken be seven again now for drawing I
can take the night which he's got all
those chicks and yeah here this is
probably maybe that's a bit risky I
don't know give me six and he should
just take him and then play this before
seems to be better for me with difficult
stuff and the way he played them why
this definitely worse it's just a pawn
but yeah here Kings he fire that's a
really cool move yeah I'm better also
with Queen takes in five okay guys
thanks for watching